I kind of always like to start with a
joke so like what do you call it when
someone has like absolute faith in
artificial intelligence naive bias right
and that's actually kind of what I want
to talk about cuz you know artificial
intelligence it's amazing and any lawyer
will tell you so here's a guy on Twitter
and he's asking for a lawyer
apparently there's a story where there's
an Irish car insurance company and what
you do when you have a car you want to
figure out how much you're gonna pay for
a car insurance is you're gonna press
every button and see what affects the
pricing so typically like red cars pay
more money it turns out this guy if he
was born on a Sunday he would pay like
40 bucks a month more than if he was
born on a Monday and so we just sort of
try all these value salad he made us
Chris would've he did sort of an
analysis and here's a guy sort of asking
on Twitter if there's a lawyer who might
want to help him out with this and you
can sort of smell sort of the
auto-generated feature tree it could
happen here maybe all this stuff went
through a giant tree forest whatever but
this is one of those moments where AI is
amazing but not always in a good way and
hey I can have this like aura of
authority that people that make people
put blind faith and this leads to this
dangerous situation and my favorite term
for this is I like to call this deep
oops
and but the real pain is when you do
deep oops that's scale and like
sometimes it really makes me giggle and
this was a random screen shot so I think
this is not in production but this is a
PayPal's virtual agent it states that to
get started simply ask me a question it
also mentions that it's still learning
so if it can't help you it will be
directing you to additional resources
someone says I got scammed and the reply
is great
and this is one of those moments where
you go okay this makes me giggle but
there are like definitely the moments
where it starts getting properly
frightening so this is something that
catherine charles shared if you're into
fairness and that sort of stuff
definitely follow Catherine she's kind
of like a watchdog what she's like a
great attitude in this sort of stuff and
she really shares interesting content I
believe it was a state of Oklahoma that
was sort of doing this essentially it
was like an algorithm in charge of
deciding how much money you're gonna get
for your health care what you know
important topic but I'll just read like
two sentences from like the suit so
during court the defendant was saying
like hey you're gonna have to trust me
that a bunch of smart people determined
this is a smart way to do it and just to
mention like a thing that went wrong
here negative changes like a person
contacting pneumonia
you know pneumonia could
counter-intuitively lead them to receive
fewer help hours because the flow chart
like algorithm would place them in a
different category and if I'm sort of
looking at this I'm sort of I tried to
sort of understand what this is
happening here and the only way that I
find that you can sort of describe this
is you know for sure it's artificial but
this is also stupidity this is behavior
that definitely shows a lack of good
sense or judgment this is the I believe
Webster definition of what stupidity is
so when I'm looking at sort of these
things happening I think it's a fair
sort of description of what I see going
on here and sort of my central thesis
and this is typically there are sort of
two things that can go horribly wrong
with models and the first thing is I
think the prime focus that we have in
industry now is that models don't
perform well on a metric that people
like like typically you want the mean
squared error to be low you want the
accuracy sorted to be high and sort of
you focus on this one metric and you
make sure that that metric is sort of
good but models can also do something
that you don't want them to and I think
as an industry we're trying to cross
validate a whole bunch of stuff and you
know that's fair but maybe we should
performing on the second thing as
opposed to the first thing and what I
would like to talk about are just what I
think are some remedies not solutions to
artificial stupidity one fix is I think
we should be predicting less but we
should do it carefully another thing
that we can do is we can constrain the
features that go into the model the
third thing that we can do which I
probably going to be my main interest to
the next couple of years we can
constrain the model itself and the
fourth thing we can do is we can
actually
doing modeling again and then I'm sorry
but I'm gonna have to show you something
fundamental which is a bit of a bummer
because there was a very unfortunate
truth to everything that we're doing
okay but happy thoughts first so let's a
ridiculous we are all familiar with
scikit-learn so I could learn is great
it's lovely library and the way that
they introduce this concept of pipeline
I think is fantastic typically how many
of these classification models inside us
I could learn work is you sort of have
like two classes and you know it's Class
A if the probability is about 50% its
Class B if it's below fair what would
you can also sort of do is you can say
well if I'm a little bit more worried
about like precision or recall on that
sort of thing you can sort of move the
threshold a bit you can say hey I want
to be very sure if it's a part of Class
A or sort of cost B in this case so now
I need it to be like higher than 90% now
this can be sort of an argument to say I
want to be extra careful when I make
this decision so this is a way for me to
sort of a sign more certainty to when
the classification algorithm does
something if you think about this what
you can then also do is you can sort of
say you know what maybe like if I want
to say it's Class A or Class B I
actually have like a certain certainty
measure and otherwise I'll just say I'll
add a label which is called won't
predict because you might be able to say
hey that's kind of like a proxy that I'm
not sure enough if it's either Class A
or Class B so that might be an excellent
moment to say you know what I'll just
not make the prediction and the picture
store that usually looks like this like
between like the array of like zero to
one when the class of probability of
Class A goes down the probability of
class B typically goes up and what you
can sort of do is you can sort of say ah
ok so one part of this would be like a
predict a one part of this would be
pretty B and the stuff that's in the
middle is too uncertain so I'll just
call that do not predict and this is
actually not a bad idea the problem
though is artificial stupidity is about
to happen and I'll show this with an
example data set and it's that can
imagine it's very counterintuitive but
something dreadfully wrong might be
going to happen real soon so here's an
example data set this is from the
scikit-learn API you can make a couple
of blobs and and this is the data set
you can kind of get and you know you
predict the color so like where are the
green bolts where the red dots where the
blue dots I mean you do like an
algorithm in this case it's K nearest
neighbor this will be had to usually
used to have and this is sort of what
the algorithm will start to predict
so you can definitely see there's sort
of like the the area where there's red
dots there's no green dots in there
anymore this is the prediction of the
model again this is like the actual data
this is the prediction so you can
clearly see the sort of this decision
boundary where it's our the one class or
another one and what you can do is you
can say I'm sort of gonna just remove
predictions that were you know if I
wasn't super certain and the decay
nearest-neighbor sense that basically
means anything that's sort of near the
borderline or like the three landmark
those are sort of moments where I say I
won't make a prediction because we can
sort of argue hey I'm more certain there
these are points that I'm certain of but
here comes a trap this is our starting
point so what I'm about to do in the
next slide these points become black and
I will sort of show you the region and
the sort of how we make a decision so
this is the original data and these are
just again all the points are made black
now but you can sort of see where the
alpha value is sort of low that's where
we are uncertain of our prediction and
where we're we are actually certain for
our prediction this for you see sort of
the thick red the thick blue in the
thick green now let's zoom out a bit I
think it's insane that the model says I
have a very high probability for red in
a region where I've not seen any data at
all that's fundamentally insane and the
blue part and the green part as well
we're assigning super high probabilities
to regions where I've seen no data at
all this fundamentally feels insane we
should not have any sort of confidence
in those regions because we should you
know we've never seen anything like that
and it's not just K nearest neighbor
here's what logistic regression will do
to the regions and here's what a random
forest will do to the regions and you
can imagine deep learning you know also
same the same issue and here's where
sort of the big issue is the output from
predict proba at best is an
approximation of probability it might be
a proxy but it's certainly not a synonym
for certainty is just a completely
different concept and this is because
and I will argue that as fundamental
machine learning models are often
designed for interpolation not
extrapolation if you're trying to
calculate the mean you're trying to
calculate the value of the middle number
the middle number might be accurate to
predict but it's the numbers on the
Verge's that are more interesting
and to sort of give a suggestion did
you're very sure about what you're doing
here can actually cause a lot of stuff
going wrong and I was a PI day to pull
in a while ago and I think the best
example of this if you're like I'm not
an expert in this but I've been told
that if you're in labor and expecting a
child what they do in the hospital is
they sort of give you a hormone to
induce the labor it's supposed to be
very helpful and the research that was
done on this and I could be like the
numbers might be a bit wrong but the
essence of it is the research that
determines the amount of hormones that
you get was based I believe on women
between 21 and 25 so you know you can
sort of make a classification algorithm
on this but to then assume that if you
are older that your home hormone sort of
system is exactly the same that's like a
really dangerous statement but this is
what the model will probably do and you
know this is a medical application it's
important when we get these things right
and and I think like it would be less of
an issue if machine learning models
weren't designed to always give a result
there's usually not a mechanism that it
sounds doubt to an outcome if a decision
is made outside of the comfort zone of
various our data but lucky for us this
last part of the problem we can actually
fix with a bit of probability glue and
this is a again I think a cool trick
there should probably be a package for
it so this is the example we had before
so what I could maybe do is like maybe
just try an outlier classification on
this like if there are adult sort of
within this realm then I'm pretty
certain I can make a pretty clear
statement but if I do like an outlier
detection thing beforehand if it's
detected as an outlier yeah then I
probably should shut up about it don't
make any predictions because that's
risky
my favorite way of doing this is using
Gaussian mixture model Oh golly there's
like so many cool things about it like
an actual probability distribution but
essentially what you do is you just fit
a Gaussian mixture on X and then you
sort of take the likelihood distribution
this determine some sort of threshold or
cutoff it kind of gets something like
this but you end up with it's just a
sort of region a couple of points fall
outside of it but only points within
this region these are points that I can
sort of consider and I can sort of say
look here I'm kind of certain what is
happening anything outside of the eye so
just sort of take a step back and maybe
like fall back to like a bit of a good
fallback scenario and I must stress that
this idea is like super general because
if I can do this on like something like
this imagine that you have like a neural
network say you train an autoencoder
first you have the anchor
our decoder part what a new sample gets
in in that latent state you can also say
look that's outlier it's something we've
never really seen before if we detect
that train some gosh and mixture unlike
the internal laden state this is an
awesome way like in general to detect
something like this from happening and
to me it like this is where stuff gets
like super interesting because I
remember like five years ago when I sort
of got started he had all these people
saying like all rule-based systems
they're going away because machine
learning is taking over and now if I
look at stuff that actually sort of goes
to production you kind of get these
rule-based systems again but these
rule-based system will have like ml
stuff in it so there's an x point coming
in if it's an outlier okay then fall
back to like a fallback scenario if then
the model also assigns like a sort of
dubious probability value okay this is a
different fallback scenario and only
then maybe take an action so you get
these sort of rule-based things in here
but you might be able to append them
with you know some algorithms and this
is a great way to keep things like
slightly more interpretive all but also
slightly safer there's less artificial
stupidity happening wait a sign system
this way I think part of the art is just
to fail gracefully not predicting given
uncertainty is a great idea if you're
uncertain about something like do
something with that uncertainty and we
can even design fallback nessa
mechanisms and unit tests in like the
situation had before that will prevent a
lot of mistakes but one thing we should
maybe you know start talking about to
our boss's algorithms merely automate
approximate and interpolate it's the
extrapolation that is actually kind of
dangerous and I want to focus on this
because mere humans with management
actually think that our models are
actually supplying us with an actual
probability it's in the language that we
are using and this is wrong I understand
that if you go up to your manager and
say oh it's an approximate proxy he will
sort of think you're poetic but but
there is something in the language here
we should sort of be you know mindful of
it's our job to care about the
production layer and we should try not
to report on an AI miracle until we
really understand one and why models
will start failing okay this is a
reasonable fix but there are other
things that can go wrong and there are
other things that we might be able to
fix as well I do think predicting less
is a good idea but we can also do step
two now and maybe sort of constrain the
features because if you think
about it you know what we feed the model
really matters like I don't know about
you but I don't want my machine learning
model to be like a Cookie Monster at
some point you maybe want to think about
the stuff that you're giving to your
model if you wanted to show good
behavior and this is kind of a
controversial topic and that's why I
kinda want to talk about it so here's
like if you take like any lot of courses
are like this it's not everyone but like
a lot of online courses or like
corporate courses they sort of teach you
how to do so I could learn but
demonstrating the the cycler and
pipeline and the pipeline is great but
what you typically do is let's say we
take the load Boston data set Boston
that data set is like the house price so
you got stuff like number of rooms and
area of town and whatnot and then you do
like standard scaling and linear
regression and then you typically make a
chart that looks something like this and
then you use this as an argument to
convince yourself that we've done a good
thing there's like a good correlation
between what we predict and what sort of
comes out we can convince ourselves that
the mean absolute error is kind of low
but the issue is when you present it
this way no one can see the actual issue
and it has to do with the data going in
and I'm not joking about this but I then
figured let's see what columns there are
in the data set there hang on through
knickers one of them is the number of
black people that live in your town
which is kind of shocking and the other
one is a lower status of your population
and I don't know about you folks but I'm
having a really hard time coming over
the use case for this data set where
these sensitive variables aren't sort of
like data laundering pre-existing bias
and I kind of get it it's like it's one
of those sort of example datasets from
the 70s and like you know world leads to
be different back then and that's
probably how this data said because it
was a favor famous back there and made
his way in the cycle Aaron but I think
it's super naive to then present this to
upper management and say oh look we got
a great model it performs very well this
is extremely naive
you should probably maybe do something
the data going into your model if you
want your model to have any sort of
fairness guarantees and I do think it's
an important topic there's a fun there's
a trick though it's not perfect but it
should help a lot so before I can apply
any sort of tricks here one thing we
probably got to do is just you know how
do we quantify this unfairness thing
right without measuring this it's gonna
be hard to say if our trick has any
effect so here's a definition that I
like it's not the only definition but
it's one that we can at least use
suppose that we have two groups Group A
and Group B I could argue that on one
level of fairness we could say look if
the predictions for Group A and the
predictions for Group B if they're sort
of always the same if like what group
you're in is not a proxy for like
difference in predictions okay that's a
measure for fairness if it doesn't
matter if you from Group A or B you're
gonna get the same prediction okay
that's that's relatively okay so what I
can do then is I can take them
predictions from my model and what I can
then say is ok take everyone from group
a look at the sort of prediction state
got do bootstrap sampling do the same
thing for Group B again do bootstrap
sampling and that the difference between
those two sort of distributions that is
if nothing else a proxy for fairness
it's sort of one thing that we can add
to our model maybe the sort of one
metric that we can sort of check hey are
we not sort of bias on sort of sensitive
variables so this is the way that we're
going to measure if sort of the trick
that we're applying has any effect and
then the first trick that you might do
is you might say okay we got our metric
how about we just drop these sensitive
columns just make sure the algorithm
doesn't let you use them and it's again
not the worst idea it's you know
whatever but we should not fool
ourselves in thinking this is enough
probably because this is a biased data
set in the first place there's probably
going to be like some correlations with
the other variables with these sensitive
columns as well so you probably have
spent like a little bit more extra
effort in sort of getting this
information out and this is where linear
algebra is sort of kicks in so one thing
that you can do and this is this look
you can kind of ignore the math but the
idea is if there are like two vectors of
data you want these two vectors to be
like independent of one another what you
can sort of do is you can say look if
this is the sensitive variable and this
is the sort of the other variable just
make sure there are thuggin all to one
another make sure that the information
they share is zero it's like a linear
algebra trick is you can do so in this
particular example suppose that this was
in the high dimensional plane a column
for gender and this was a other column
say income you can at some point then
say okay let's just filter out all the
gender information for all the other
columns like this and then we can sort
of see what happens and again I must
argue this is a trick and I just want to
demonstrate what it might do so let's do
the experiment what I'm gonna do is I'm
just gonna show you the normal situation
that I have before I'm gonna show you
the situation with the two columns that
I think are sensitive that I've drawn
and then I'm doing the same thing but
I'm also filtering out the information
in those of those two columns I'm gonna
filter up all the information for the
other columns so what you're gonna see
this is again the first model you're
gonna see the the scatterplot of like
that will be predicted and what we
actually got out and this is sort of the
proxy for the fair fairness so this is
like a distribution of difference
between the two groups note by the way
that this is on a scale for my 10 to 50
and unfairness here is on a scale - like
on average - 12 so okay the unfairness
is actually quite significant here this
is what happens when I drop the two
columns the mean squared error is
relatively the same but we and we
actually see that this sort of fairness
proxies a little bit moving more towards
zero but we're not out of the woods yet
like it's sure it's an improvement but
you know still a lot of overlap here's
what happens when I filter out the
information out of all the other columns
okay still not quite zero a whole lot
closer and the interesting thing here is
you're also able to see that okay when
are we making sort of errors in our
prediction because you know the mean
squared error really sort of skyrockets
here but one thing you can kind of see
the the moments when the unfairness sort
of happens the errors that I'm making in
this model those are for like the
lower-income sort of areas which is
exactly sort of the information that I'm
trying to filter out it can kind of
measure here that the data set is sort
of biased we're just if you're probably
lower-income you're definitely gonna get
like a lower house rating and the fact
that the mean square error goes down
that is a bit unfortunate because it
might feel that you're sort of in this
moment now where you can sort of say god
dang I got a sort of pick it's either
more accuracy or it's more fairness and
this is really unfortunate because I
don't exactly expect corporate
incentives to you know align here to put
it lightly but I will remind you there's
actually a thing that we learned the
moment before that we can do now because
if nothing else what we can do now is
you can take like the highly accurate
model we can take the highly fair model
and when there's a difference between
these two models that's a very good
proxy to maybe not make a prediction and
it turns out you know we can totally see
a pattern here this is like a pattern
that you can learn on the y-axis you see
sort of the skew and fairness and this
is sort of the the base prediction you
can definitely see that there's like one
region of points where I might be more
comfortable making a prediction
and in most other situations I can sort
of say right this is unfair the model
should do like definitely a fallback a
human being needs to look at this we
shouldn't have automate this decision
now I do want to mention here this is a
trick this is a tactic fairness in
general it's like a much larger topic
but a thing that's really hard in this
space is that fairness typically is in
the eye of the beholder and sort of
there's a sort of an issue with this
because what I find fair might not be
the thing that someone else finds fair
but above this issue there's even harder
issue like I like the trick I just
showed you I like the fact that the
fairness is sort of like the the
unfairness thing is definitely sort of
going to zero I think this is good
that's a nice thing but in order to
apply this trick to cost fairness with
regards to income and skin color I need
to know the income and skin color if I
would not have had these columns in my
dataset in the first place as we saw
before there would still be much much
much unfairness in there and will be no
measure for me to sort of compare and
this might mean that fairness is gonna
come at the cost of privacy here and
I'll so this is I understand it's kinda
like a controversial topic but I do want
to sort of make one argument here
fanners at the cost of privacy might be
a bargain and let me cynical here I
would hate for companies to sort of say
we're aren't allowed to know your gender
therefore we cannot sort of do this it
will be a shame if stuff like that
becomes an excuse to not do fairness and
as we saw before not including the
variable in your model is simply not the
same as being fair it'll be like if we
cannot have a metric that can help
people accountable there's it's gonna be
hard for me to come up with a trick
maybe two guarantees any form of
fairness and again that's where the
beholder comes in important topic kind
of outside of the scope of the day but
there is sort of a trick where we can at
least say look there's some sensitive
variables I want to correct for that I'm
on my model not to be a Cookie Monster
I want my model to be more like
nutritious Elmo I also want to mention
here just like before this whole
constraining features trick is also
potentially useful for deep learning
approaches you sort of do the same trick
within a laid in space and okay beware
the analogies like I'm I don't think
analogies actually work all the time it
we're in embeddings it's a different
talk but for man-woman we we've probably
heard of the man-woman king/queen thing
well imagine you then have sort of this
direction where you so to say okay
that's sort of what man
woman means and there's like bias in
there that we would like to filter out
same trick make it orthogonal make sure
that the information you have in all the
other vectors is sort of kept equal and
then maybe man woman starts pointing to
the word embedding that means gender a
little bit more and then maybe King
Queen starts looking at the same word
embedding maybe for royalty there are
sort of these tricks that you might also
be able to apply outside of the scope of
like tabular data but you might be able
to do some of this stuff in deep
learning walls as well I have some
experience with this not so much yet but
I do think is a fair thing sort of keep
in mind the variables that you put into
your system and how they are processed I
think are more defining in the end
result than whatever machine Ling
algorithm you're gonna be using after as
far as I'm concerned I really like
seeing modeling pipelines where you
explicitly select columns from a data
frame just taking your X and chugging it
into a machine learning model feels very
very unappropriate especially when stuff
like this can be going wrong
understanding what goes into your model
matters and everybody here should care
if the data if sort of the predictions
going out of your model is your
responsibility and so is the data going
in and at this phase sort of okay we can
put we can decide not to make a decision
we can also decide to put our model on a
diet but what we can also maybe do is
just you know pick models where this
sort of stuff just comes as a guarantee
and it sort of introduced what I mean by
that
my background is an Operations research
so the stuff that I typically do is like
optimism icing systems and that sort of
thing so one common like homework
assignment is like suppose you've got
some data set of like returns for a
stock what you can then do is you can
say okay stock one has a certain type of
return and stock two is a different
return we're gonna sort of spend money
in such a way that the returns gonna be
as high as possible
oh this system of like this math system
will be really stupid if you didn't have
something like okay but we shouldn't
exceed the budget we're allowed to make
any investments but we have a certain
amount of budget and we should never
really go over that I also think the
system will be kind of silly if you
didn't do something like ok but a
certain allocation has a certain risk
maybe you want to make sure that we
optimize the profit but you know subject
to that we want to keep the risk at an
acceptable level this calculation will
be really really weird if I didn't have
those two constraints
and what I might be able to argue is
that we are sometimes designing machine
learning models where we're really just
doing the maximization well we might
need to be caring more about is that we
actually add constraints our system you
know to come to a better outcome this
exercise like with the constraint yes
the return on your investment is going
to be lower but you simply don't care
because it's a more meaningful thing to
calculate and maybe we can start doing
this sort of thing in machine learning
as well and there's a couple of
constraints like there's many of them
but I'll just discuss three here some of
them are numerically difficult but three
constrains that you can already kind of
add our monotonicity fairness and label
guarantees so what do I mean with
monotonicity well there are these
systems where at some point you can say
look I don't if we ever come up with a
model where more smoking leads to more
health that's bad I have enough domain
knowledge to say that should never
happen so maybe I should just make a
system where I can sort of say look
there's one column relationship - why
should always be strictly negative or
strictly positive the health care you
got many of these situations and
definitely the pneumonia thing will be a
thing we might be able to catch for this
turns out though there are systems that
sort of do this you can write for a
single variable you can sort of write
the relationship down this way and this
thing is actually already implementing
this I could learn it's called isotonic
regression and it's stuff that sort of
looks like this
it basically says okay you're allowed to
sort of go up but you still have to sort
of minimize the square error you're
never allowed to go down or vice versa
you can wonder when does this matter
well there's a bunch of moments but one
of the things that can go wrong is
imagine you've got this outlier so you
know I know for certain that people who
smoke should be less healthy but if I
were to give this to a random forest
you'd get this suboptimal and if you
give it to a nice monotonic regressor
you get this you can still do some stuff
like outlier removal before you give it
to like the proper pipeline but again
this is one of those guarantees that you
can give to your system such that less
stupidity happens and I do think in a
lot of cases we have enough to main
knowledge to sort of declare a few of
these variables to sort of be you know
monotonic it might be thinking like gee
are we like limited to simple models
well first of all simple models aren't
limited I just like to point it out and
second of all no there's actually like
really complex models that you might
want to use for this so believe it
tensorflow has this thing called lattice
it allows you to sort of specify to
certain things that go into your model
our monotonic decreasing or increasing
they sort of do some nice numerical
tricks and the idea basically is if you
have sort of a latent state where a
monotonicity comes in it should also go
out and by doing that you can guarantee
that you know these constraints exist
but extra boost also has this and this
is just a screenshot from their docks so
here's the model where you see that the
monotonicity is not enforced but if you
just turn up the flag it is enforced so
there are actually already lots of
systems and models where you sort of got
this sort of thing and I would really
love it if people who are just you know
blindly putting stuff into actually
boost to maybe pay attention to this
because you know potentially you might
do a lot of good by doing this another
thing that we can do you know with the
fairness thing we had in mind you might
be able to also add a constraint for
fairness you know maybe there is a
fairness I want to guarantee based on
someone's gender and maybe on someone's
race as well turns out if we are
considering a linear system this already
exists there is a paper of it and
there's a bit of an approximation going
on here the idea basically is you look
at the decision boundary and you just
want to make sure that the sort of the
distance from like different groups with
respect to the distance to the decision
boundary sort of I kept that day but my
colleague might ice Browns who sits over
there by the way he actually made an
implementation to this and we could
actually show unlike the data set that I
showed you before if you tweak this
coefficient that we can also sort of
guarantee that a certain amount of
fairness is kept at bay again it's sort
of just only the linear system here but
by changing the coefficient value we can
see that if we are very strict with this
coefficient the fairness goes up and the
accuracy sort of goes down a bit but
this will allow you to maybe design
system saying I want the highest
accuracy but I want my fairness to
remain at this level and no worse I have
two other colleagues Stein and Hank and
I sort of made a neural variant of this
this is also more popular you can
probably find this an Internet the idea
here is you just make a deep neural
network where the first part of your
network just tries to predict like the
loss like the accuracy but then based on
this metric you train a second network
that tries to sort of predict the
sensitive variables and if this network
is really able to sort of the
adversarial that's really really able to
sort of predict things like race and
gender
well then probably your models not being
fair
and you can sort of put that into the
lost function as well and it's actually
like a cool gift like I'll just let it
run once and the idea is you see sort of
the distribution between income
predictions and as we're training and
training accuracy sort of goes down a
bit but the probability sort of fairness
satisfaction guarantees they sort of go
up and up and up and it's sort of a nice
way to sort of change the cost function
such that you know sometimes you care
more about accuracy and sometimes you
care more about fairness but this is a
way to keep things in balance again
designing systems like this are probably
systems that have more of a chance to
survive you know out there without the
need of lawyers decisions were just
throw everything in and journey you sort
of do cross-validation and just do that
another thing that I think is kind of
interesting this is definitely sort of
in a new domain area but how about we
make constraints for detection how about
there's like a few data points that we
have in our data set that we must
guarantee that they will predict it
correctly there's also a constraint you
can add to a system and sort of my
dreamy use case to this might me and my
girlfriend we sometimes watch Netflix
sometimes only chose accounts it will be
amazing maybe that instead of Netflix
just measuring my data I as a user can
also upload a constraint to Netflix for
example I can say look you're giving me
this recommendation for this one show
but I just don't want to see it imagine
now that we can design systems that way
instead of just learning a cost function
you might be able to actually add
constraints and the way that this sort
of stuff feels to me at least numerical
issues aside when you think about modest
way a whole new world of modeling just
sort of opens up instead of overfitting
our design concerns like a a a cor you
see but you might can actually sort of
design a system by thinking we actually
got this order you know design things
again it's not just you know take your
data in such a way that we can chuck it
into this mixer it's like now let's just
do something with us and the best
analogy I kind of have for this is like
what I look for clothing I try to look
for clothing that fits me when I see a
t-shirt that I really like it's pretty
useless unless it fits me there's also I
think a bespoke suit is better there's
no better Vincent that will fit in this
suit but there is a better suit that
will fit this Vincent and sometimes if I
look at some people doing machine
learning it is starting to feel like
we're doing this right because this is
what one size for all dot fit sort of
looks like and I will be making an
argument for
attitude at least that maybe we should
be moving a little bit away from modeled
outfit and maybe a little bit more
towards like tailored modal because
we're tailoring a model there's less
unexpected issues we have the
opportunity to design a system that's
like actually super articulate and we
could also more easily answer questions
about assumptions without resorting to
like basic metrics and there's a common
theme to all of this because if I if I
start thinking about a model this way
the maybe our model is nothing more than
like learning from data you know times
whatever constraints that I have
hmm so just like that bespoke suit maybe
we need to accept that you know the
model the fit is incredibly naive and
maybe we start to need to maybe do
things with people in physics do but
people in physics try to do is they
really try to study a system such that
they can come up with a very proper
model that might be able to explain
everything and I have one final example
and I might go a little bit over time to
explain this example I hope you don't
mind but it's an example it involves
chickens and we have to be careful here
something incredibly dangerous is about
to happen but I'm gonna show you a
really cool trick but also like really
cool trick but something gained you're
still gonna happen sorry about that it's
a real life so does the original data
set this is the chick wait data set is
my favorite data set that I use for
trainings and you're about to learn why
essentially there's a couple of chickens
that are born and then they get a
different diet and the idea is hopefully
we can check you know if you get a
different diet you might grow a little
bit fatter and the meat industry is sort
of interested in that now what you can
then do is you can sort of say okay I
want to predict the weight of a chicken
based on the time in the diet and one
way is sort of doing this is you know
just make a wall hunting coded variable
for the diet and then you can chug it in
the pipeline and there you get a model
it sort of looks like this but this
model is just like wrong all over the
place for starters chickens are born
with the same weight it makes no sense
to have like a constant value and then
if you were born on like day 0 you just
weigh more completely unsensible is
totally not how the world works and if I
start thinking about this problem like I
can actually describe the way the world
works because essentially it's still a
linear regression but I want to be the
zero of like the intercept term on that
to be the same for all the chickens but
the slope that's the thing that's gonna
be different for every single diet oh
and by the way we also kind of see that
the noise increases over time so maybe
that's Sigma we can also sort of split
that up over like the the chickens and
in the diet they put this in PI MC 3
which is you know a precious library
it's always super fun to use but and
like something magical happens cuz you
can sort of see that there's this one
diet that has like the best effects for
growth and that one diet also well
there's two diets that have the best
effect for growth but one of them has
like a much lower variance so note how
this model is way more articulate I can
actually sort of talk to this model and
I got uncertainty bounds and all that
stuff is epic and I've like perfect
explain ability I've what if questions
that I can have
there's useful hypothesis test but and
there might be human bias but
unfortunately I'm about to show you what
will always go wrong in machine learning
there's one giant problem if you take a
look at this data set you will notice
that there are certain chickens who died
prematurely this might be due to the
diet our model has no way of capturing
this until we tell it to but yeah I
don't want to put them all into
production where you know dead chickens
are sort of a possibility bummer
this entire talk i've spent talking
about side effects of our models that go
unnoticed if we're not careful but even
what I will argue here is the best model
this can really fail if we don't
understand the problem that we're
solving we might be building a system
that's gonna end up producing a whole
lot of dead chickens but there are some
remedies and consider maybe not
predicting I mean it's a great way to
remove risk but be careful about what
you use as a definition for certainty
and consider maybe constraining your
features that go into your model
optimality definitely goes a lot further
than means criteria consider models that
constrain because they're great you know
you can sort of give a guarantee for
something you're afraid of and you know
give this whole time c3 invasion systems
thinking a try it's really nice that you
can articulate what you want to model
but most importantly take a step back
and think about what you're doing
because we really need to be aware of
these debts chickens they are bound to
happen and this is that like you need to
be a human to sort of really figure this
stuff out so with that in mind
maybe natural intelligence isn't such a
bad idea
please grind yourself to creative
freedom to understand the problem is I
think this will help you a great deal in
designing whatever solution you have one
more thing I've been talking about a
bunch of algorithms and tools in this
talk and very often I've noticed that I
sort of talk about some tools and tricks
that are very useful but then on Twitter
I sometimes get the reply like oh
implementing this is still kind of
tricky and I kind of recognize the fact
that it's much easier to sort of do
these sorts of systems and stuff if
there's actually like an open-source
implementation of it so I'm very happy
to announce that me and Mattias and a
bunch of other colleagues and like a guy
from Brazil we have this new open source
project called psychic Lego the idea is
it's kind of like an opinionated package
but I've noticed that all of our
consultants were sort of implementing
the same estimators and transformers and
that sort of thing and at the moment we
actually have an information
filter implemented in here that we'd
love to get feedback on the fare
classifier again make my math ice also
in here and we're kind of hoping that
this can be like one of those packages
where there's just sometimes this need
for like a kind of a weird or quirky
transformer and we kind of have a place
where we can put that and we will make
sure that there's like some tests for
them as things that can remain clean I
would love you to sort of play with this
so thanks and we actually have stickers
for this you can get them at the non
focused and after
[Applause]
okay so I think we're okay ish on time
or can I do like one more joke what do
you call a Swiss algorithm a neutral
Network sorry I there might not be time
for questions or is there and we've got
lunch next right so I'll be here asking
anything if not have lunch enjoy the
conference we can have like two one or
two questions but lunch is next so it's
not - I'm fully aware of them between
you folks and lunch so like if you won't
have lunch it's fine I'll be here but
enjoy the conference
[Applause]